head coach of LSU football after that
big huge win over Texas
coach Oh a tour Geron joining me here on
the Rich Eisen show how are you coach
we're doing great great great to have
you back walk me through your decision
to just turn Baro loose right there on
third and 17 we will not stop at a more
deeper steve has make it did a great job
on that drive Joe made a great plays try
never to learn made a a great block on
the Blitz and line package or slid in
the middle and just have made a great
catch and ran for a touchdown out there
what a great play for the tight when do
you make that decision obviously you
know there's a few seconds before a snap
on third and 17 walk me through what a
coach thinks
button-pushing seeing how everything is
going down in a big spot like that in
Austin yeah
trust about the plan there police are
out quarterback would have an
outstanding quarterback we always felt
that looking it if I can get to protect
Edwards around here on the Rich Eisen
show you said after the game and it was
a big statement what statement did that
make that win well the statement you
know they give credit to Texas they
fought they were top it was a great
atmosphere that quarterbacks would be
one of the best quarterback we've seen
it was a battle to go and be the top ten
teen on the road and ran faced adversity
we although we'll a bevel behind face
adversity and we have to do bail so how
does this how does this provide you what
you need to move forward then well you
know we're stay to get better we have 31
announce points at bay scored 31 points
in the second half when I pleased about
so we're gonna have to get better at
that continue to do the things on
offense that we do get better with
defense to get to where we need to go
how much better can borrow me though you
know he's pretty good right now here's
some things you get better at your we
get better at the run game but right now
the way he's playing is phenomenal well
I say this with the ultimate of respect
what's gotten into him I know he's good
and he has been great but he has been
superlative he has been just remark
over the first two weeks and especially
again in a crucible spot like Austin
yeah that's what he wants he's a gamer
he's a baller he loves he loves the
competition this is Joe's team he's more
comfortable around us he moved in from
Ohio took over didn't know the players
very well not a player's believed in
them this is his team he's working with
these receivers all summer long
relentless I was in the classroom well
with Joe Brady and Stephens finger and
the guys just a ball of man he loves the
game letters are in here on the Rich
Eisen show some gamesmanship here as
well
did your band get forced to sit in the
nosebleed section 30,000 fans show up
they put our band in the nosebleed
section but you know what we're from
Louisiana man we're going to fight so
that didn't say we could hear loud and
clear we're proud of them and I'm sure
we're gonna have something for them when
they get to come to Tiger Stadium next
year well what do you got what do you
mean are you reserving the the section
at the top at the top of the stadium
right now for the Texas okay and or
cleanup duty for Bevo something like
that okay here on the Rich Eisen show
and the offense so much is being made
about the 21st century spread offense
that you are employing with borough
right now when you when you hear that
what do you think when people are saying
we haven't seen an offense like this out
of LSU before you always want to say it
hard it took a little while to get it to
get the right people in here get the
wide receivers obviously get the right
quarterbacks evening our good friends
you know we've come a pro-style offense
and we did it USC and what we did in
Miami but we needs to go to the spread
and we found the best guy to help us
learn the spread is Joe Brady a young
guy who I always wanted to say so I
wanted RPO from Penn State East coming
in and put it in as Steve done a
tremendous job of calling along with Joe
our guys believe in that's working
and do you believe that you're the best
team in the country right now we don't
know that you know I know a good
football team but I know this that when
we play well we click it overall surface
will be hard to beat
we we did not click all sellers Saturday
night we played well on special teams we
although we had to go long stands we
played well in the first half we have to
play a complete game for 60 minutes this
SEC is tough we are taking one game at a
time yeah I know you got Florida you've
got all burned both of them at home and
then you've got a visit to Alabama how
much do you keep your eye on other
schools as you matriculate your way
through this a seasonal schedule which I
just take it one game at a time one day
at a time we have Leicester state coming
in this weekend today's Telugu Monday
there will be a mile celebration going
on what I'll put a key 24-hour rule and
tomorrow will be focused on beat
Northwestern State and just take it one
game at a time
what did you call Monday what is it
called tell the truth Monday I'm walk me
through what this is please well what we
do is we tell the things that we did
well with of the team we show the things
because well we show them the things
that we busted will improve
Donald Monday if I made a mistake in the
coaching on in the game management I'll
tell them
this is our family we tell the truth we
put it on sale but that will go forward
is it a two-way street to the players
get to tell the coaches some truths or
no Leadership Council meet those guys
boys they can okay so the truth is
somewhat of a one-way street in in a
team meeting is what you're saying right
okay but the doors always open for this
street to be flipped to go always open
okay all right this is exciting times
top five now for your school how do you
I guess another coach in your conference
calls that rat poison I'm wondering what
your thoughts are for your team to look
up and and see all the accolades and
hear about them rock out the noise good
bad
I learned this from Coach Carroll at USC
you just can't believe with it with the
rebus when you when you win they make
you too good and when you lose to make
you too bad so you know we got to be
able to control what we can control
focus on the LSU Tigers and so far we
have great leadership on our team but
we've done that okay and do you pay
attention with the Saints are gonna do
tonight I mean I'm a big good at-bat I
love the strong faith it's a great coach
Ryan Nielsen who of course the u.s. is
the defensive line coach
I'm friends with all those guys Mickey
Loomis we love to rephrase we're big
fans of the Saints okay and if you smoke
in his eye on Williamson have you met
him yet speaking of big we did offer
them a scholarship Oh
when when he was in high school hold on
a second now walk me through that one
coach at origin what was that yeah yeah
we had a young tiny graduate assistant
coach named Eric Mateus who watched him
play basketball and offered him a
scholarship so we won a few schools that
offer a football scholarship and what
happened no response even respond to
your offer to play tight end at LSU is
that right II didn't respond I wouldn't
get much of a response okay well he
could have brought him to the state of
Louisiana before before the pelicans
finally did all right one last serious
one for you and then one one more fun
question for you coach Edwards you're on
scheduling putting Texas on your
schedule and vice versa second game of
the season it's just becoming so rare I
mean fans just cannot get enough of
games like this straight out of the gate
and it seems so many schools are either
shying away from that or unable to do
that I'm wondering what your philosophy
is on that scheduling oh I'm bored
especially when you went obviously but
you know you at LSU you got to compete
at them at the top you want to compete
with other teams at other conference you
want to see where you're at especially
early in the season it tells you a lot
about your football team and the only
way to learn about your football team is
to play the best so we played a great
team in Texas these guys they'll go a
long way
well did you um did you are you for any
sort of uniformity though where
everybody's got to do this where
everybody's got to play in the SEC
everybody has to play a caliber of a
school that when you schedule them
that's their caliber like Texas would
you be up for uniformity nationwide on
this coach no opping footballs you play
with any conference and be able to
schedule our conference games and I
think is it a quality of school
according the athletic administration
the head coach the football team
you just can't do the teams that you
want to scare the weak students to
compete at the highest level that tells
you and that's about us all right and I
saw a tweet after the game I'm sure
you're not in charge of the Twitter
account there at LSU where you are the
Minister of Culture of LSU did you see
that tweet that there's somebody sent
out there we have some cages come cook
up some jambalaya white beans and rice
fried shrimp and fried catfish you're a
bit we're rich it'll happen is that
right we had a great meal that's nice
great celebration okay very good so did
you say anything to the Texas Minister
of Culture Matt McConaughey did you say
anything no no I like that I was just a
few Tigers with a football game we did
it we got out of town I'm glad to be
back back in that room all right and and
and tea with hot tea with lemon and
honey for that voice coach I'm always
concerned about it sounds like you're in
postseason for Moroni with that voice of
yours we're ready to go okay take care
of yourself coach thank you my friend
you got it thanks that's adores you're
on here for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
for free on BR Live or download the Rich
Eisen show app